J'ai grandi à New York, j'ai grandi
avec quatre frères et sœurs, mon père gagnait à peine de quoi subvenir à ses besoins,
nous avons déménagé chaque année et nous nous sommes finalement
installés dans un lotissement pour
familles à revenus moyens inférieurs. Nous sommes allés dans des
écoles publiques et en fonction des programmes
de transport scolaire.  et des déjeuners comme la
plupart de mes amis
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Applaudissements] [
Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mon père était architecte et il nous apprenait toujours à
lever les yeux  dans les bâtiments et il était
vraiment passionné par le design et
nous allions avec lui dans
différents musées de design et tout
ça et j'ai de très bons souvenirs
[Musique]
quand j'étais enfant, ma mère faisait toujours
des moments particulièrement durs ma mère  sauriez-
vous qu'il est temps d'essayer
autre chose et que vous savez qu'il a
peur de
[Musique]
[Applaudissements] [
Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Je n'y pense pas vraiment, l'idée
de la célébrité  cela semble juste très nouveau et
peut être assez étrange parfois vous pensez
pourquoi vous savez que vous voulez être vous
ne le voulez pas c'est très nouveau pour moi
donc je l'ai, je ne suis pas encore blasé
mais je pense qu'ils savent que c'est  euh, il y a
les côtés positifs, vous savez, je suis pour
la plupart positif et puis certains des
côtés négatifs
[Musique]
mon personnage est courageux, elle est vulnérable
et c'est une femme
[Musique]
Je suis très fière d'être une  pouvoir être
une mère qui travaille et vous savez, je pense qu'il est
très important que les enfants voient leurs
parents satisfaits de leur travail
[Musique]
Je pense que face au
climat politique actuel, il est vital que nous  nous avons
tous pour mission de devenir vraiment très
personnel, alors oui, à 15 ans, j'étais allé
chez un gynécologue. Je vivais à New
York et j'avais visité un centre de Planned
Parenthood là-bas, aucun jugement, aucune
question posée. Planned
Parenthood fournissait un endroit sûr
où je pouvais être soigné.  avec
des conseils doux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Je veux avancer et pour moi,
avancer signifie que ma fille grandisse dans
un monde où elle n'a pas à être
victime de ce qui est cruellement devenu la
norme sociale selon laquelle elle ne le fait pas.  doivent s'adapter
aux contraintes de la
condition féminine.
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
lorsque des acteurs non transgenres jouent des
rôles transgenres, cela continue en quelque sorte à
propager l'idée que
les personnes transgenres n'existent pas ou que  nous ne sommes pas
réels ou que nos identités ne sont qu'un
costume que quelqu'un peut mettre et
enlever à volonté
[Musique]
c'est vraiment intéressant parce que vous savez,
lorsque nous recherchions un réalisateur, vous
commencez à voir certains des
problèmes systémiques que vous  sache et vas-y wow, c'est vraiment
même à la recherche d'une réalisatrice qui
a eu suffisamment d'expérience pour pouvoir avoir
l'opportunité d'avoir cette
expérience, tu sais, s'asseoir à la tête
de quelque chose d'énorme comme celui-ci, tu sais que
les choix sont limités à cause de ça  et
ça et ça craint
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Président Trump, je n'ai pas voté pour vous
qui avez dit que je respecte cette URL
président élu et je veux pouvoir
vous soutenir mais d'abord je vous demande de me
soutenir, de soutenir mon  ma sœur, soutiens ma
mère, soutiens ma meilleure amie et toutes
nos copines soutiennent les hommes et les
femmes ici aujourd'hui qui attendent avec impatience
de voir comment vos prochains mouvements pourraient
affecter radicalement leur vie.